on commence sur une anecdote de qualité
j'ai appris récemment que quand je
parlais que je m'appuie sur la gorge
comme ça je risque de me créer des
nodules sur les cordes vocales et des
nodules qu'on s'est extrêmement grave
eh ben tu fini par perdre tes cordes
vocales voilà donc ça m'a mis en place
toute la nuit dont le petit plus ce
genre de choses je dors mal après les
amis il y à quelques temps nous avons
testé mon skill en géographie qui est
équivalent au tient sur 20 h à savoir
bronze
souvenez-vous ont commencé sur une vue
aérienne d'une ville très zoomer et on
pouvait dézoomer un petit peu et fallait
deviner de quelle ville il s'agissait
aujourd'hui sur géo guest alors il ya
plein de gens qui ont déjà fait des
vidéos tudou mxn d'ailleurs mais je m'en
bats les couilles géo gaza utilisent
google style ça veut dire que tu te
retrouve vraiment dans les rues de la
ville je pense personnellement que c'est
plus facile de deviner ou tuées quand tu
es dans les rues de l'endroit où tu es
aux primes cette phrase plutôt que
d'avoir une vue aérienne on se rend
compte de rien là c'est parti
la géographie de squeeze partie de
hockey on est dans le jeu intense amédée
saga gelé quoi dans des pétroliers on y
est c'est carillonneur en espagnol c'est
pas comme s'il y avait un milliard deux
pays qui parlent espagnol et basse ok ça
va être à base d'inspecteurs squeeze la
maison là-bas le toit et de travers
alors est-ce que c'est lié à la caméra
360 de google sûrement sur ce camion ses
marques et en espagnol
d'accord c'est un pays où on roule à
droite comme en espagne et peut-être
aussi au mexique près du site où les
ouzbeks pagnol [ __ ] m'attend si bien
c'est qu'on peut se déplacer on va y
avoir la bataille mais comme dans un
repaire de routards mon pote incroyable
que des camions le climat a l'air plutôt
sec 15 et basse plane uno suarez mecs en
espagne ou c ou étant axée sur des
services de station en station service
géré en soi est inspecteur squeeze c'est
génial at on choisi la sphère publique
en espagne du sud-est non je sais pas
robles hôtels et cabanas ce soir n'est
en amérique du sud soit on est en
espagne attention à ça sans mes traces
pousser les routes à ce match france
espagne c'est parti et l'espagne ok ok
j'ai mis le curseur sur l'espagne
attention j'étais à dix mille quatre
cents kilomètres de la location correct
on était en argentine [ __ ] on va se
rattraper alors viendra propre et vert
blanc rouge attend puisque là on le voit
pas très bien cette si je vais là il y
aura un peu moins de vent et on le verra
mieux dans un camp pirates en blanc que
l'on voit parfaitement le drapeau ah non
là bas à la marque et stoppe donc c'est
en français tu pensais le canada mc et
canada
oui j'ai reconnu tabarnak je suis allée
yapo longtemps et j'ai reconnu le
drapeau vert blanc rouge rouge blanc
vert j'ai déjà plus avec la feuille
d'érable que j'arrivais pas discerner à
cause du vent merci à tous merci c'est
tout pour moi
make 3000 points on était calmes 900 kg
de bois près par contre où au canada
qu'elle me toi et reste tranquille à son
chien merci c'est que paris montréal ça
fait quatre fois paris mais il ya deux
fois plus d'habitants à paris qu'à
montréal ça fait réfléchir les neurones
alors sa mère climat extrêmement violent
la chaleur est totale nous sommes au
milieu de la campagne il énormément de
verdure et de poussière nous sommes en
plein cagnard
il ya de la fumée on ne sait pas
pourquoi par terre ah ok parce que je
regarde derrière la douche ça va vous
être sur google donc je me tape les
projections ok il ya une vache mais qui
peut avancer j'irai au bout de cette
route j'en ai rien à [ __ ] ou c'est
parti
est-ce que la vache avait plus l'air de
venir des us ou d'afrique ça la vraie
question pour les cours trouvent une
bâche ya une maison il ya deux autres
vaches on les voit à peine à temps sans
succès aux usa est en train de manger un
burger mon pote sociaux à ses obligés
c'était ok les pays au sud sud du brésil
le mec ça a fusé [ __ ] regard humain
mais je suis dégoûté [ __ ] mexes est
bâtard de vache elle s'est dit je vais
trompé tous les joueurs en en juin
burger jeu là et mec tout est pareil
c'est quoi je dirais que c'est
l'australie tout est pareil tout est
linéaire russie mais mec en russie déjà
thema la taille du pays il ya tous les
paysages possibles et imaginables en
russie allez on y retourne alors au
séchage total sécheresse mais ultime tu
touches le sol tu transformant en flaque
de poussière c'est beau un mec c'est
trop beau c'est la jungle nathan c'est
peut-être un truc genre une île c'est
une île paradisiaque où les riches y
vont en vacances à regardait ça c'est
une personne riche
ils ont étendu le linge de cette
personne riche sur un fil en or mecs
trop bien je vois ça je pense à des
insectes et animaux extrêmement
dangereux pour moi c'est l'australie ça
s'arrête là [ __ ] je vais l'autre côté
c'était au brésil une nouvelle fois oui
c'est tout président luc hamel brésil
c'est magnifique mais faut qu'on aille
au brésil venu au brésil demain tous
ensemble on fait un petit airbnb à 8
millions c'est que tranquille alors là
déjà d'après la balance des blancs de
l'image je dirais que c'est une
luminosité qui correspond à l'europe ce
métro bon en gros c'est juste une route
avec des chants mort elle va mettre au
pif c'était la france cet endroit nul
c'était à bazoches alors attends boîte
aux lettres américaines on aux us
la peep d'inspecteurs squeeze
c'est le texas ça m'étonnerait pas de
voir chuck norris traversé comme ça au
fait où je pense qu'on est au texas à
l'etec sa salle à la veille mais bel et
bien texte annonce était dans le
colorado que chaz colorado qu'est ce que
c'est finalement moi ce que j'ai envie
de faire c'est les endroits connus les
famous place au quai n grande roue il ya
un pont avec de l'eau il ya des fantômes
ya big band est excellente c'est le pont
il a big ben ne me prenez pas pour un
coût non plus ça va oui j'étais cac 1,6
km à les rounds suivants aulas il ya un
désir oil déjà je n'irai pas dans cette
ville pour cette raison et un starbucks
on aux us fait une bêtise mais je sens
que c'est new york c'est new york j'ai
vu sur les fall streets et new york
ou alors je vous ai menti en réalité
j'ai vu que saubusse il est marqué new
york city peut-être possible oui et bim
[ __ ] mais qu' heureusement quoi on les
bâtards et nous invite dans un bâtiment
attend peut-être par la fenêtre on va
voir un drapeau ou un bus avec marc
kenis ça c'est clairement une statuette
d'amik scène je pense qu'on est chez mxm
enfin des trucs comme ça pour moi c'est
l'italie donc je vais dire italie
malheureusement mon manque de culture
fait que je ne serai pas deviner quel
bâtiment c memex ac italie c'est obligé
on va dire rome
[Musique]
c'est le château de versailles que j'ai
visité mangé des petits bonds se parle
je me suis fois et ça arrive alors
[ __ ] mec sait où ça déjà
samedi un truc voilà la blague que 100%
des youtuber ports régionaux feront en
tombant sur paris merci à tous alors
grâce à mes nombreux voyages je peux
vous dire que ça c'est du coréen et que
nous sommes en corée etc on est très
chanceux parce que sur cette image on
peut apercevoir des triplés et c'est
très rare d'en voir n'a en fait j de la
mer je pensais en chine nymex totalement
shinji de n'importe quand j'ai dit 100%
de la merde les coréens veulent me
flinguer par contre ou en chine
j'y suis jamais allé comme la chanson de
granby snc shanghai bim on n'en parle
plus haut à shanghai allez hop c'était
pékin bas c'est pareil tout change
toutes les lettres séparées 14600 point
on est presque pas un culte
on est là c'est quoi ça c'est très
probablement en chine c'est shanghai
faites moi confiance et shanghai et ben
c'était yann bizien je connais même pas
cette ville alors remarqué fois sur son
guide merde on veut pas voir ah ça c'est
du chêne au liban d'asie sein des los
espagne y a pas voulu que je fais à
merde ça c'est bien sûr à madrid c'est
au mexique parce que pour moi qu'il ya
de l'espagnol en en espagne mais c'est
faux à ça je connais ça y'a pas
longtemps j'ai appris dans une vidéo ses
axiane je vais vous montrer où aller
voilà elle n'est pas très connue elle
n'en est pas moins très charmante voilà
vous finirez moins bête alors on est où
il ya un trou dans le ciel et c'est à
dire tout ça n'est qu'une supercherie et
qu'on est en fait dans une pièce en
réalité augmentée https en ut je suis
désolé je vais dire un mec du nord est
ce que j'en sais rien je n'étais pas
loin c'était à en dakota du sud et ça
c'est pas dubaï ça avec la tout comme sa
pièce [ __ ] heureusement que j'avais
regardé en allant au japon les le top
des taux les plus hauts du monde grâce
bout on dirait disneyland à stanislas
mec sait où mais c'est trop vous avez un
petit train touristique de nancy je
pense que cette annonce si je sais pas
qui tire cette compagnie de petit rat
nancy mais un gros big up a toi escape à
une map juste en france voir si j'arrive
à me repérer en france paris c'est parti
est-ce que je connais bien ma propre
ville c'est ce qu'on va voir
alors il ya un jean claude biguine ça
c'est l'avenue mozart mais évidemment
dans le 16e arrondissement où je suis
tombé à 198 mais qu'est ce que tu vas
faire ok suivant bien sûr oui oui je
connais bien ce type de briques bien sûr
ces débris du 11e sardou est par ici ça
easy money dans le jacuzzi au mini
coiffure c'est mon coiffeur je sais
parfaitement où c'est mémé coiffure
arrêter avec ces noms de salon c'est à
cause de vous je me suis retrouvé à
avoir cette coupe de cheveux par peur
des chez le coiffeur 17000 point je suis
officiellement
par ici
ok on termine par d'autres endroits très
connu dans le monde c'est quoi ce pont
c'est le pont d'avignon ça en france
c'est sous le pont d'avignon on y danse
on y danse oui ça milowe mai mais qu'à
des endroits incroyables sur la planète
ça me donne envie de voyager de hoffman
ce dock et tué des hommes genre tu
rentres tu tombes direct bim dans le
grand bain incroyable c'est alors mon
avis c'est à las vegas avec les portes
bling bling et ou alors peut-être parce
que j'ai vu qu'ils aient marqué de las
vegas sur ce but je sais pas et voilà
mec un vrai mec ses manières d'apprendre
la géographie en s'amusant sans déconner
c'est cool et les années n'était pas la
même chose si elle vous a plu à jouer à
ce jeu il est extrêmement cool [ __ ]
mais trop intéressant de découvrir
d'autres paysages qui sont drastiquement
différents j'écaillé drastiquement ça
m'a donné envie de voyager mais c'est la
rentrée hérité on est tous en paix allez
à bientôt
[Musique]